a group of current and former metro  canine handlers are suing the department  for  unpaid overtime and contributions to  their pension  jeff corbett seen in this video from  last december  is one of four handlers named in the  lawsuit the others  are john jenkins scott murray and david  newton  according to the lawsuit each handler is  asking for more than 15 thousand dollars  in pension benefits  due to the long hours required of k-9  officers  they also argue they are due thousands  in unpaid overtime  because of all the time spent caring for  their dogs off the clock  according to the lawsuit metro police  says they do not comment on lawsuits